bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver à la une de ça vous regarde ce
soir le coronavirus gagne l'europe le
virus se propage en italie cinquante
mille italiens sont confinés dans le
nord du pays et près de 300 cas de
contamination ce soir la france elle se
prépare des mesures préventives ont été
prises dans les écoles le coût
économique de cette crise sanitaire
mondiale est immense on en parlera
coronavirus une pandémie est elle en vue
c'est notre grand débat ce soir les
retraites à présent la pression monte
autour du 49-3 le gouvernement
s'arrachent les cheveux pour déterminer
la meilleure fenêtre de tir pour des
galets cette arme constitutionnel le
débat nuit est toujours englué dans
l'hémicycle mais la majorité et
l'exécutif ont décidé d'attendre encore
un peu pour rendre ce passage en force
plus acceptable alors en attendant nous
verrons dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission quels sont les grands 49,3 qui
ont marqué l'histoire de la vème
république et puis notre grand témoin ce
soir à presque tout était dans sa vie
chansonnier journaliste essayiste patron
de rabiot patrons de presse tout sauf
consensuelle philippe val est avec nous
ce soir voilà pour le programme c'est
parti est axée vers n'oubliez pas on ne
va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir philippe
balle bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
en direct journaliste essayiste ancien
patron de la rédaction de charlie hebdo
de france inter tu finiras clochard
comme ton zola c'est le titre de votre
dernier livre c'est une autobiographie
mais c'est aussi romanesque c'est aux
éditions de l'observatoire on en dira un
mot récit à la troisième personne
adressez à votre fils mais l'actualité
ce soir c'est ce coronavirus qui gagne
certains pays d'europe
après le nord de l'italie de nouvelles
régions sont touchées la toscane et la
sicile plusieurs cas en espagne un cas
en suisse également question ce soir
l'épidémie peut-on en parler oui ou non
pour l'europe et la pandémie en est on
l'a ou pas on se pose la question avec
vous jean louis tourenne bonsoir vous
êtes député la république en marche du
rhône professeur de médecine est
spécialisé en immunologie ce qu il vous
intéresse particulièrement ce soir
philippe juvin bonsoir et merci au chef
du service des urgences de l'hôpital
européen georges pompidou ap-hp marc
lazar bonsoir vous êtes historien
professeur à sciences po paris et
spécialiste de l'italie contemporaine et
eric heyer
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
économiste à la fc eux
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques merci à tous les 5 de
participer à cette émission en direct je
vous donne la parole dans un instant
mais celui qui nous plante le décor de
ce virus ce virus qui arrive c'est
stéphane stéphane blakowski si j'ai bien
compris tout de suite
[Musique]
vomir et un bonsoir messieurs le virus
qui arrive c'est moi donc le corps un
virus est de retour montlaur temps qu'il
était à lâcher en chine effectivement
même s'il y avait des centaines de morts
bon on était désolé évidemment mais on
se disait c'est quand même loin de chez
nous et puis voilà maintenant que le
virus est à nos frontières
en italie on se demande mais comment
faire pour l'empêcher de rentrer chez
nous heureusement ce matin le ministre
de la santé était sur rtl il s'est
montré rassurant ces informations
quelles sont elles
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui à l'heure à
laquelle je vous parle il n'y a plus de
malades en circulation en france n'y a
plus de malades hospitalisés le dernier
patient est sorti guéri hier de
l'hôpital de lyon vous posez la question
du risque zéro est ce que on est sûr à
100% qui a pas un malade contaminé sur
le territoire national je ne peux pas
vous répondre
alors moi je fais toute confiance au
milieu de la santé 1 je suis vraiment un
légaliste de ce point de vue là mais le
problème c'est que coronavirus et une
info qui évolue très rapidement ce qui
était vrai le matin n'est pas forcément
vrai l'après midi donc cet après midi on
a découvert par exemple y avait deux
nouveaux cas en france qui n'était pas
encore le cas ce matin à repérer et puis
par là et olivier ferrand il s'est dit
bon l'italie c'est inquiétant mais pas
tant que ça on écoute ça c'était ce
matin
vous savez on a on est à 2 120 malades
identifiées en italie 20 patients en
réanimation sept décès c'est beaucoup
mais l'italie aujourd'hui en train de
circonscrire les zones et a mis en
quarantaine les zones dans lesquelles il
y à des malades et n'a pas identifié de
nouveaux kloster de nouvelles zones
voilà ça c'était encore pour ce matin je
le disais de nouvelles régions 1 avec la
toscane et la sicile en italie donc plus
les hédonistes page en italie plus
l'inquiétude
elle se propage en france donc sur les
réseaux sociaux bien sûr on va faire
reculer les rumeurs détour du complot un
virus malfaisants qu'on aurait créé dans
un laboratoire n'importe quoi évidemment
mais même dans la vraie vie des
quelqu'un est prise ou kern de tout on
sent que ça inquiète et plusieurs cas en
france est chauffeur de bus qui tous et
beaucoup en revenant de turin il ya eu
un gars d'origine chinoise dans le
trezia bon à chaque fois ils ont été
testée est bon qu'ils n'étaient pas
contaminés mais on va quand même que ces
cas existent et que la perspective d'une
épidémie qui toucherait la france ben se
rapproche en tout cas même le premier
ministre qui était ce matin sa famille
et pardon devant les députés
l'idée d'une épidémie mondiale qui donc
toucherait elle aussi la france n'est
plus écartée tout indique qu'il est en
train de se transmettre un peu partout
dans le monde et que nous nous trouvons
dans une situation qui pourrait se
traduire par une épidémie mondiale
et puis mondial épidémie mondiale le mot
est lâché
ça veut dire quoi concrètement pour se
protéger la question ce sont les
frontières faute il est fermé bah ça
c'est la solution du front national du
pardon prat semblement nationale mais
est-ce que ce que c'est surprenant pas
vraiment c'est la solution qui propose
un petit peu pour régler tous les
problèmes pour lutter contre
l'immigration va on renforce les
contrôles aux frontières pour lutter
contre les importations bas on renforce
les contrôles aux frontières donc pour
lutter contre le choléra coronavirus bas
la solution marine le pen a forcément
elle est toute trouvée pour alain je
demande le contrôle de nos frontières
j'ai l'impression de demander la lune ça
paraît être la première encore une fois
des mesures de bon sens à mettre en
oeuvre que de contrôler leurs frontières
alors et parle de mesures de bon sens
marine le pen serait que ça paraît
peut-être du bon sens après tout face à
un virus nouveau prendre des mesures
fortes peut-être même autoritaire mais
c'est pas si évident bien sûr le cas
italien fait réfléchir eux ils ont voulu
prendre des mesures fortes en disant non
les avions qui viennent de chine ne se
pose plus chez nous voilà comment on se
protège
on n'hésite pas et le résultat si on a
bien compris c'est que d'abord il des
gens qui sont contaminés qui sont
rentrés parce qu'ils ont pris les
correspondances et que donc la
conséquence et qu'on les a pas vu venir
donc on les a pas identifiés et on est
incapable de les deux tracés leur
parcours ce qui est déterminant pour
pouvoir lutter contre l'épidémie
donc on a peut être l'impression que les
solutions autoritaires
elles sont nécessaires parce que la
crise sans de s'aggraver mais on voit
que la chine est un régime autoritaire
qui n'a pas su contrôler l'épidémie et
que le deuxième pays le plus touché
c'est l'iran voilà un pays autoritaire
qui lui aussi a été dépassé par le virus
ce qui peut peut-être nous rassurer un
peu je dis bien un peu c'est que le taux
de mortalité qui reste assez bas 3%
abba parlez pour vous meriane ça c'est
un taux moyen mais ça dépend beaucoup de
l'âge alors vous avez moins de 50 ans
forcément donc à peine plus de trois
pour cent le taux de mortalité mais moi
j'ai plus de 50 ans hélas le taux il
passe à 12% regarder chacun va pouvoir
se situer dans ce petit graphique viriat
pas de quoi être à sion je me suis
renseigné figurez-vous que l'âge moyen
du député ses 51 ans à moi non vraiment
une population à risque
il suffirait qu'une canne de tous à
l'assemblée alors je peux dire que la
réforme des retraites
ou alors on est très près de terminer je
moi je pense que les insoumis vont être
pris de quintes de toux et merci
stéphane on va reprendre un peu tous
tous les sujets parce qu'il ya plein de
choses dans votre papier philippe juvin
d'abord la crise italienne
j'aimerais comprendre pourquoi on passe
de 3 2 6 4
coronavirus assez vendredi à 283 ce soir
comment on peut exploser le nom contre
le nombre de galeries nation d'une
épidémie il ya des patients qui n'ont
pas été détectés qui ont circulé qui ont
affecté d'autres
et puis le cycle infernal s'est mis en
route on considère qu'un patient malade
peut contaminer probablement 4 5
personnes pour la grippe ces deux donc
voyez il ya une contamination plus
importante et il n'a pas été fait ce
qu'il faudrait faire dans cette
situation c'est à dire que dès que vous
avez quelqu'un qui est à risque il faut
l'isoler c'est ce qu'on fait en france
on le test pour savoir s'il est malade
et s'il est malade on met en quarantaine
parler du patient zéro c'est ça c'est en
être retrouvés en mairie qui a mis du
temps à être retrouvées il a eu
probablement le temps lui aussi de
contaminer suffisamment de monde qui eux
mêmes ont contaminé des gens et le fait
que ça paraisse brutalement n'est pas
surprenant puisque la période
d'incubation pas et de deux à douze
jours
eh bien il ya une dizaine de jours il a
rencontré un certain nombre de gens et
ces gens ces genres
développer la maladie entre deux touchés
à une progression exponentielle petits
chiffres au départ est ce qu'on sait ce
qui s'est passé dans l'hôpital et
italiens il ya eu un dysfonctionnement
manifestement on ne sait pas je pense
qu'il faut faire attention à tout tout
est raconté à la réalité c'est que nous
en france qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on
a un patient à risque on l'isolent
immédiatement il va pas dans la salle de
la tente par exemple aux urgences quand
il a le malheur d'arriver aux urgences
et en isole et on le teste et s'il est
positif
eh bien on lui en 40 annecy n'est pas
positif on le renvoie chez lui et le
fait qu' il ya plus de contrôles en
italie qu'en france est pourtant plus de
40 dit m vous faites référence au fait
que les italiens très tôt ont mis des
contrôles à l'entrée aux frontières mais
le sujet c'est que ça rassure tout le
monde les contrôles sauf que qu'est-ce
qu'on contrôle en fait on contrôle rien
est-ce que vous contrôlez la température
il se trouve qu'à des gens qui en
coronavirus qui n'ont pas de fièvre mais
il ya des gens qui ont des fiefs qui
n'ont pas de corps en fait c'est encore
hélas élèves qui prennent du doliprane
et en plus donc tout le sujet si vous
voulez et c'est toute la difficulté du
coronavirus et qui a aucun signe
spécifique qui permet de dire oui lui la
wii lui il ne l'a pas ça c'est un vrai
sujet gardien peut être question il est
possible de ne pas avoir de symptômes
d'un autre patient 01 entendu et c'est
raide il ne rien ressentir alors qu'il
était curieux très c'était l'un des
sujets absolument fondamentaux dans
cette maladie c'est qu'on a une forte
proportion de patients qui n'ont pas de
symptômes et donc qui contamine
tranquillement son même savoir que eux
sont malades
c'est pour ça que sur le havre de virus
et ne même pas s'en rendre compte
absolument c'est pour ça que la notion
de taux de mortalité dont on parle n'a
pas beaucoup de sens parce que pour
avoir un tout-droit s'élancer oui mais
pour avoir les qualités il faut un
numérateur et un dénominateur le
numérateur c'est le nombre de morts donc
on connaît à peu près mais le
dénominateur c'est le nombre de cas mais
si vous ne testez personnes eh bien vous
avez un taux de mortalité et que vous
détestez que ceux qui vont mourir
vous avez 100 % de mortalité en fait
c'est ça qui vous comprendre aux fonde
personne ne sait exactement le nombre de
cas alors on se marre et la question de
l'afrique va être une question
fondamentale
là on en parlera à un petit peu plus
tard marc lazar restons sur l'italie
vous avez des étudiants qui sont
d'italie vous avez des contacts vous
allez nous parler un peu de l'état
d'esprit des italiens notamment dans
cette région du nord mais en parler de
cet hôpital vous avez des informations
le gouvernement compte t a reconnu un
dysfonctionnement et même une surprise
par rapport à la manière dont les choses
sont propagées rapidement alors surprise
par rapport aux premières mesures qui
ont été prises qui ont été beaucoup plus
drastiques la france puisque
effectivement il ya eu des tests dans
les aéroports mais des tests de
température dont vous expliquer que
finalement il était assez inefficace il
ya eu la suspension des vols vous l'avez
rappelé entre l'italie et la chine entre
la chine et l'italie ce qui fait que
manifestement des passagers venant de la
chine sont passés par la france par
exemple pour revenir ensuite en italie
donc à pas la traçabilité qu'on a
instauré en france a été un problème
comptez le président du conseil a
reconnu dimanche sa surprise par rapport
justement mesures qui avaient été prises
hélas depuis 48 heures il ya une
controverse une polémique même qui a
surgi puisque le président du conseil a
accusé la région de lombardie faut
toujours se rappeler que les questions
de santé dépendent des régions en italie
c'est un élément très important du point
de vue institutionnel et donc des
pratiques de santé publique et donc le
président du conseil a attaqué le
président de la lombardie en disant que
justement dans l'hôpital de codognan les
mesures qui avait été suggéré par le
gouvernement national n'avait pas été
appliquée or le président de la région
et membre de la ligue
jusqu'ici ce qu'on appelle la ligue du
nord mais qui effectivement très forte
dans la ligue dans le nord de l'italie
et par conséquent jusqu'ici il y avait
plutôt un bon climat de coopération
entre le président de ces puissantes
régions faut jamais oublier que c'est
les régions les plus riche de l'italie
qui sont touchés ou les structures
hospitalières sont particulièrement
performantes et là ce qui est inquiétant
c'est qu'il ya eu un cas difficile c'est
à dire sans vouloir être trop
désagréable pour le sud de l'italie la
santé le niveau central au niveau de
l'italie du nord est donc maintenant il
ya une controverse politique et les
petits début de l'unité nationale des
forces politiques pour essayer justement
de lutter contre cette épidémie est en
train d'être rompu ces fragments sont en
train de naître mali et depuis
quarante-trois trois jours
matteo salvini demande même la démission
de président du conseil et ses questions
politiques on les aura en france 1 s'est
pas résorbée l'italie si jamais ça
arrive en france et si jamais il ya des
alliances déjà commencé vous avez évoqué
la position de marine le pen imaginons
je parle sous le contrôle des autorités
médicales ici représentés si jamais il
ya plusieurs cas évidemment les forces
d'opposition mettront en cause le
gouvernement la majorité parlementaire
on va y revenir à la france dans un
instant vos contacts parce qu'on a eu
l'impression qu'il ya eu un petit vent
de panique au départ week-end dernier
les magasins sont vides et rapidement et
en même temps que les choses sont un peu
plus stabilisée non il ya deux choses
d'un côté c'est vrai qu'à une panique et
c'est moi j'ai effectivement des
étudiants qui ont voulu rentrer très
rapidement nous avons pris des mesures à
sciences po très drastiques
aujourd'hui puisque nous demandons à
tout le personnel administratif les
professeurs et les étudiants qui
viennent de la chine de la corée et de
l'italie du nord de rester chez eux et
donc de suivre les cours par voie
électronique si c'est possible donc
c'est des mesures sévères qu'on a adopté
en france
et puis il ya une inquiétude il ya une
inquiétude vous savez tous nos étudiants
en troisième année partent à l'étranger
beaucoup choisissent italie en
particulier l'inversé de la bocconi
donc est ce qu'on fait est effectivement
ma j'ai eu des témoignages d'étudiants
qui sont rentrés mais il ya encore tout
à l'heure là je sors d'un séminaire où
un étudiant italien me disaient qu'ils
repartaient dans sa famille à vicence et
il m'a dit donc que quand je rentrerai
pas obligés de rester pendant quinze
jours chez moi à paris avant de revenir
en cour donc voilà c'est des choses de
la vie quotidienne le gouvernement les
autorités essayent de développer un
discours visant justement à ne pas à ce
que la population qui joue oui joue gros
puisque déjà une impopulaire il est
attaqué systématiquement par son
opposition
et puis joue sa crédibilité européen
international jeudi à un sommet franco
italien s'était pas l'ordre du jour ça
va être à l'ordre du jour il y avait une
réunion des ministres de la santé hier
alain ferrand pays européens le sommet
aura lieu à naples jeudi et évidemment
je pense que le prison mâcon qui se
rendra à naples avec vos cra cette
question avec ses interlocuteurs italien
alors justement est ce que nous en
france on est près comment la france
prépare on a entendu
marine le pen à l'instant exigé la
fermeture des frontières elle considère
d'ailleurs que nous ne sommes pas
véritablement protégée on va écouter une
députée c'est la députée des alpes
maritimes lé de la république en marché
elles considèrent et bien que c'est
absolument inutile d'en arriver là
écoutez son argumentaire à l'heure
actuelle c'est totalement ridicule et un
faisable faire des contrôles aux
frontières ça voudrait dire quoi ça
voudrait dire prendre la température des
gens attendre la période d'incubation
qui en moyenne de 14 jours dont bloquer
des gens pendant 14 jours et savoir si
oui ou non ils ont le quoran au virus et
après les faire partir donc à l'heure
actuelle c'est totalement irresponsable
et l'édicule comme proposition bien
évidemment qu'il faut faire des
contrôles bien évidemment mais les
contrôles sont faits au sein même des
communes à des collectivités on voit que
l'italie a pris les mesures qu'il
fallait en faisant des zones de
confinement la france en fera aussi si
c'est nécessaire mais à l'heure actuelle
à l'heure où je vous parle il n'y a
aucune raison d'imaginer une fermeture
des frontières
d'autant plus qu'elle ne serait pas
efficace un virus ne s'arrête pas une
frontière quelle qu'elle soit un virus
ne s'arrête pas aux frontières qualifiée
soit jean louis touraine
elle a raison de dire ça la députée de
votre majorité
un virus comme le nuage de tchernobyl ne
s'arrête pas aux frontières
effectivement c'est tout à fait exact
pour autant on doit en quelques mesures
évidemment moi je dirais votre question
était de savoir si on est bien préparé
en france mettrait trois niveaux
différents
sur le plan sanitaire on est très bien
préparé on est un des pays au bond et ça
a été reconnu par des experts
internationaux
on est parmi les six ou sept pays au
monde les mieux préparés à faire face à
des epide employés sur le plan intérieur
on a un maillage d'hôpitaux un perso
centaines de médecins
ces cinq-là passé d'accueillir les
malades y compris voilà des chambres à
l'isolément exactement parfois même de
l'intelligence respiratoires on a tout
ça tout ça même si des routes cas même
si on a davantage bien sûr bien pris la
tête des hausses les moins fortes que
sanitaire formé alors après ensuite il
ya le plan de la communication
communication de crise c'est jamais
facile
la france était très mauvaise il ya 25
ans parce qu'on voulait rassurer les
gens et pour ne pas induire de panique
on minimisait la réalité sauf que
quelques semaines plus tard on est
obligé de se contredire et c'est très
mauvaise a donc vous voyez s'il ya un
foyer par exemple au niveau de la
frontière près de vintimille il y aura
des y aura forcément des zones de
confinement est probablement une
fermeture de frontières qui viendraient
contredire
ça c'est le troisième point c'est
l'organisation c'est l'organisation
administrative qu'il faut mettre en
place c'est à dire tendre à isoler les
cas on les isole comme ça a été fait aux
contamines comme ça sera fait dans les
autres foyers qui se développeront très
probablement parce que je crois que de
fait nous sommes à l'aube d'une pandémie
celle ci est très probable quand on voit
le nombre de pieds déjà atteint et et là
chacun pouvait nous donner la définition
d'une pandémie précisément pour ces gens
feront pas grave d'épidémie au niveau
mondial c'est sûr vous italie la
précaution
c'est inévitable personne n'est de 20
personnes de demain à abandonner une
épidémie va vers le déclin il semble
mais c'est trop tôt pour l'affirmer que
la chine soit sur cette phase de
diminution des des cas les autres pays
l'iran l'italie et les autres pays qui
sont touchés sont au contraire on a
phase ascendante
donc il est absolument impossible de
dire ce qu'il en sera pour l'instant
l'afrique n'a pas encore rapporter 2,2
nombre de cas substantielle mais mais il
n'y a aucune raison pour que ça ne se
développe pas aussi en afrique est
malheureusement là il ya des pays qui
n'ont pas notre infrastructure de santé
publique et kiki qui rendront les
mis encore plus redoutable on l'a vu
dans d'autres cas d'épidémie donc vous
voyez bien qu'il ya ces trois dimensions
la communication s'améliore et on dit la
vérité aux gens et je crois que c'est
bien
et cette vérité il faut pouvoir même
dire nous ne savons pas ce qu'il en sera
dans quinze jours ce dernier point que
ça entre un petit village comme
contamine on peut confiner ça ça paraît
évident mais si ça arrive à lyon à venir
comment on fait pour confiner lyon est
bien visible que de confiner dans
certains quartiers c'est à dire il n'est
pas possible ni pour lui on est pour
paris de dire que toute la ville
on peut pas fonctionner une ville comme
dans la taille de mourad comme l'ont
fait les chinois
j'en profite parce que vous êtes des
députés de lyon il faut que ce match ait
lieu mercredi
turin il faut que les joueurs puissent
jouer c'est un les supporteurs ce dès ce
serait mieux qu'il reste en italie à
trois c'est mieux pour eux alors en
france philippe val c'est important
parce que il ya une question
démocratique aussi qu'il se pose comme
oh là on a tout de suite une forme d'
utilisation politique de ce qui se passe
ou en tout cas une demande très claire
sur les sur les frontières sur le repli
sur une gestion nationale les frontières
pour les frontières marine le pen de
toute façon elle est pour la fermeture
des frontières
quoi qu'il arrive elle est pour la
fermeture des frontières il ya l'euro à
l'épaule à sortir des frontières parce
qu'elle veut faire comme le brix i télé
pour la jeunesse aux frontières du coran
d'un virus et les pour la fermeture des
frontières ce qui a des réfugiés et les
pour la fermeture des frontières de
toute façon
donc on appuie sur un bouton elle est
pour la fermeture des frontières
vous qui avez traversé une frontière
eric et avec des attentats terroristes
est ce que on s'attend à ce genre de
situations qui sont pas comparables ça
n'a rien à voir mais tout de même une
unité nationale dans le moment comme ça
on parle de daube de pandémie il ya eu
17 avril n'y a pas eu de d'unité
nationale l'ailé elle a duré très peu de
temps au niveau de la population il ya
eu une unité mais dans les partis
politiques il n'y a pas eu d'unités elle
s'est vite déchiré très vite il y en a
qui ont justifié très rapidement les
attentats terroristes sans justifier
mais en dix ans mais il faut comprendre
enfin bref de toute façon il ya des
oppositions très violente aujourd'hui
juste on a de la chance d'être dans des
démocraties ce camp quand il y a des
problèmes sanitaires comme ça dans les
dictatures c'était très bien décrit par
foucault dans surveiller et punir
comment on quadrille comment on a un bon
un bon outil la pandémie est un outil
pour asservir pour voir exactement tout
ce qui se passe dans la population pour
violer la vie privée pour empêcher la
liberté fondamentale d'aller et de venir
ça devient un prétexte on a de la chance
de ne pas être en iran né en chine
je pense que le mot pandémie n'est pas
encore utilisé officiellement parce
qu'il y ait un rapport de force semble
t-il entre entre l' oms
et si jean ping et la chine parce que si
jean ping a joué sa crédibilité en
disant ça ne sera pas une pandémie parce
que la chine est capable de contenir
or dans les jours qui viennent on va
voir peut-être que c'est pas vrai mais
c'est un vrai problème pour jean ping
c'est un problème politique
la chine est plus fragile peut-être
c'est une dictature très féroce mais
peut-être plus fragile qu'on ne pense et
cette histoire de pandémie est une star
politique pour eux mais nous que ça
devienne un problème politique dans nos
démocraties c'est de l'irresponsabilité
de la part des acteurs politiques
il faut évidemment une unité parce que
on peut faire confiance dont le voit
d'ailleurs sur le plateau de télévision
la qualité des experts les gens
s'expriment très franchement est très
bien et très clairement et on sent aussi
que
le gouvernement a fait le choix d'une
transparence totale être communiquée au
maximum 6 6 voilà au risque de se
contredire par bien sûr dans la même
journée qu'hier elles sont quelques uns
des frontières c'est pas des murs de
verre les frontières c'est symbolique
c'est une histoire c'est une histoire
c'est de l'histoire tout simplement les
frontières et évidemment que les virils
et que c'est le foot des frontières que
cette crise
cette épidémie interviennent à un moment
où la défiance vis-à-vis du politique
nord est si important c'est ça le promet
alors marc lazar là dessus je crois que
c'est ça le point font danser salmonella
l'heure parce que le vrai enjeu sinon il
ya une vraie des scientifiques qui est
donne tous les éléments d'informations
que vous avez je m'adresse à vous
puisque vous avez cette compétence aussi
et ça c'est important et je crois qu'il
ya tout un effort de pédagogie il ya un
effort de politiques publiques du
gouvernement et qui essaye aussi de dire
un certain nombre de choses pas
simplement de rassurer mais de faire de
la communication
mais le problème c'est que ça arrive
dans un moment de profonde défiance sa
défiance qu'on enregistre dans les
enquêtes qui sont faites par nos
collègues du cevipof est absolument
énorme c'est une défiance pas simplement
par rapport à la classe politique mais
par rapport aux medias par rapport aux
universiades par rapport aux experts et
donc il ya déjà sur les réseaux sociaux
l'idée mais qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière
c'est pas vrai on nous cache la vérité
et ça ça va être le grand enjeu de cette
crise lié à l'épidémie ça va être si
j'ose dire très intéressant pour
l'observateur plus difficile à vivre
sans doute pour chacun d'entre nous on
est très mal éduqués démocrate est on
est on est on vit dans des démocraties
qui sont les moins mauvaises possibles
donc ils sont plutôt bonnes d'une
certaine façon puisque nous on a des
libertés fondamentales sont garantis et
pourtant le personnel politique
une partie du personnel politique et mal
éduqués parce que il ils le prennent
n'importe quoi dans l'actualité pour
faire pour s'opposer frontalement à
l'heure aux partis opposés il ya une
violence dans le débat politique
une impossibilité d'imaginer qu'on
puisse convaincre l'autre qui se traduit
dans la société ça décrédibilise il
devrait y avoir des sujets si on était
bien éduqué démocratiquement il y aurait
des sujets sur lesquels la droite la
gauche peuvent faire du consensus
surtout sur des sujets colle à la
majorité n'a pas vraiment pu montrer le
bon exemple et agnes
qui a fait le reproche en pleine
campagne à anne hidalgo de ne pas avoir
pris des mesures
anne hidalgo a dû montrer un courrier
que ça vienne de la part de partis
contestataires mais là c'est il ya une
compétition pour la gestion eric heyer
on va parler de l'impact économique
on va essayer de est-ce qu'on peut le
mesurer c'est une question déjà mais
mais sur ce test pour les démocraties
alors là c'est plutôt européenne et
peut-être même après occidental
quelle est votre analyse parce qu'on a
vu aussi que finalement les dictatures
ou en tout cas les régimes autoritaires
n'était pas forcément mieux armés que
les démocraties face à cela oui donc à
votre question c'est est ce qu'il ya une
réponse européenne est ce que cet
ensemble est ce que c'est un c'est un
moment de vrai défi mettre au fond le
fait qu'on ait l'habitude de lire de
circuler librement de pouvoir contester
de pouvoir changer qu'on voit là ça ça
nous renforce où ça nous a faibli face à
à cette épidémie
c'est très difficile il répond mais
alors effectivement on peut se dire
qu'on est aussi dans une dans un
mouvement dans la construction
européenne qui était extrêmement
difficile et donc le repli sur soi était
déjà là avant ce virus et il est
possible que ça renforce ce sera sans
doute pas la bonne idée ni d'un point de
vue économique ni d'un point de vue mais
ça c'est pas mon champ de compétences du
virus mais il va falloir qu'il ait une
réponse européenne
c'est évident lorsqu'on est ministre on
t'as faim tu as roma l'ami de la santé
pour déjà coordonné un peu plus les
choses
amo là dessus oui ça ira t il ya une
chanson que chanter et serge reggiani
allons corps qui s'appelait les loups ou
les loups sont entrés dans paris un
savon et on voyait qu'à la fin les gens
ont appris un peu assez mais à être
solidaires pour eux et c'est ça qui a
fait disparaître l'épidémie glousser de
façon peut-être qu'il ya une leçon à
tirer de ça de quentin danger est au
dessus de nous quand un danger nous
dépasse c'est peut-être le moment de
réfléchir au civisme à la solidarité je
dis des trucs de langue de bois
peut-être même et c'est pourtant du réel
il va falloir être comme ça il va
falloir apprendre être d'accord sur
certaines choses et pas s'affronter sur
tous les sujets alors en plus il va
falloir aussi travaillé beaucoup sur la
vérité des choses parce que les gens qui
s'informent à des sources sûres
ne sont pas majoritaires en france
surtout parmi les enfants ils vont
sommes s'informer sur internet
il n'a pas n'importe sur les réseaux
sociaux sur le sujet parmi les mesures
prévues contre la pandémie pourrait nous
confirmera y avait l'idée de mettre des
soldats devant les pharmacies donc quand
on en arrive à imaginer ça donc c'est un
plan qui est prévu en cas de pandémie
c'est à dire qu'on a quand même faible
confiance dans la le citoyen l'esprit
civique de nos concitoyens on s'attend à
un débat des bagarres on s'attend de la
pension pas si évident de ce qu'on vient
de vivre plusieurs de 20 au plus d'une
année de violence sur des sujets divers
en france dé violence hallucinante en
démocratie des violences physiques alors
que normalement le débat doit régler
beaucoup de choses là ça c'est vrai il
ya eu des bagarres dans la rue et
beaucoup de choses brûlé casser des
blessés nourrir davantage la violence
ben il peut être que le discours
politique pourrait induire sa induire
que attendait il faut être solidaire
face à ça c'est une maladie c'est un
virus donc peut-être qu'il va falloir
réapprendre à s'entendre à se comprendre
et à se respecter afin dé vous dans les
années 80 de l'épidémie de sida
souvenez-vous qu'après une phase où il y
a eu des polémiques
jean-marie le pen déjà disait
construisons décida thorium et c'est dé
discrimination contre les homosexuels
contre les toxicomanes quand c'est
contre les malades séropositifs
on a trouvé après en consensus c'est un
fait il a mis quelques années s'est
inversée il était hélas pour le fait les
politiques les différents leaders
d'opinion les journalistes les les les
acteurs enfin l'ensemble des personnes
ont montré une solidarité qui a entraîné
en définitive toute la population
française de telle sorte que il y a eu
des souvenez-vous des sidaction qui ont
été recueillis des donations des dons
très important d'arrêter française est
devenue soirées festives sont tannés
plus rapide
là j'aurais compris
il faudrait que les gens deviennent
voilà solidaire en se disant il ya
quelque chose qui est quand même plus
grave que nos petites différences
exactement parce que je voudrais quand
même interrogé eric heyer sur ce qu'on
peut comprendre au fond de tous voilà
ces entreprises qui craignent pour foule
de voir leur chiffre d'affaires fondre
comme neige au soleil hier l'économie
mondiale elle a la fièvre elle aussi les
grandes places financières sont
quasiment toutes dans le rouge les
entreprises sont très très inquiète
alors le cours des valeurs refuges lui
grimpe voit cela avec clément perreault
au pied ensuite votre décryptage juste
après le coronavirus représente une
menace sérieuse pour la croissance
mondiale l'impact annuel pourrait être
de 0,1 à 0,2 pour cent selon le fmi pour
la france bercy table pour le moment sur
une baisse de 0,1 pour cent pour la
chine
la chute devrait atteindre 1% ces
chiffres correspondent au scénario
plutôt optimiste d'une épidémie qui
toucherait son pic au milieu du mois de
mars
les constructeurs automobiles ne se
hasarde pas à donner de chiffres mais la
chine est le premier marché au monde
elle représente 40% des ventes de
general motors et volkswagen 30% de
daimler et bmw
les ventes de voitures ont baissé de 92%
en chine au mois de février il y
actuellement 30 à 40 % de touristes en
moins qu'attendu en france à cause du
coronavirus en 2019 la france a
accueilli deux millions de touristes
chinois dont un million en ile de france
c'est la 5ème nationalité de touristes
étrangers mais la seconde pour les
dépenses
un touriste chinois en france déboursent
en moyenne 198 euros par jour
[Musique]
les conséquences sur la demande de
pétrole sont significatives le baril de
brent a perdu près de 15% depuis le 1er
janvier l'épidémie fait plonger les
bourses mondiales lundi le dow jones a
connu sa pire séance depuis deux ans
avec un repli de 3 56%
pendant ce temps à paris le cac 40
perdait 3 94%
recueillie confirmé aujourd'hui avec une
nouvelle baisse de 1 94%
eric heyer est ce qu on a une idée à ce
stade de l'impact économique du grenelle
et russes sur l'économie mondiale n'ont
pas à ce stade hisser les scénarios
enfin enfin un scénario alors il ya des
scénarios extrêmement optimiste et celui
qui a été décrit dans votre reportage
c'est à dire que c'est une épidémie qui
reste vraiment circonscrite à la chine
et qui ne ne vient pas dans les autres
pays est la même le 1% sur la chine mais
me paraît extrêmement optimiste nous
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de données dures
les seules données dures que l'on essaie
au niveau du trafic et et là on
s'aperçoit que c'est pas on devrait de 3
3% de croissance à 3,2 c'est ce que
dirait le fond il devrait passer d'eux
s'ils sont plutôt à six nommés sur
l'ensemble de l'économie mondiale et 2
et de 6 à 5,6 pour cent de croissance
pour les chinois nous aujourd'hui on est
plutôt ils sont assis ce qu'on est
plutôt ils vont passer à quasiment zéro
au 1er trimestre et donc sur la moyenne
sur la moyenne de la de l'année
imaginons qu'il ya un rebond au deuxième
trimestre ce qui n'est absolument pas
assuré
on serait plutôt aux alentours de 4 2 4%
dont un prêt serait de 6 à 4 et donc un
passage de 6 à 4 quand on connaît le
poids de la chine dans le commerce
mondial
ces îles sont ils sont aujourd'hui ils
représentent 40% de cette croissance
mondiale et donc du coup ça va faire
plus tôt une croissance mondiale qui
effectivement est aujourd'hui en 2019
tourne autour de 3% à quelque chose qui
devrait tourner aux alentours de 2%
mais ce sera beaucoup moins mais et donc
forcément il y aura un choc relativement
violent et ce n'est pas un choc de
pandémie encore une fois on est sur un
scénario uniquement d'épidémie bien
entendu parce que là c'est vraiment un
choc
encore une fois ce n'était pas si grave
que cela dans le sens uc et
conjoncturels oui c'est conjoncturel
dans les landes
c'est une catastrophe naturelle une
catastrophe naturelle généralement il ya
un énorme choc ponctuel et ensuite un
rebond alors ensuite sur votre moyenne
annuelle ça assez marqué mais c'est pas
grave il nous notre scénario c'est que
la chine repasse au-dessus des 6% en
2021 donc voyez passer
oui c'est possible aucune famille est
possible mais il faut s'attendre à
quelque chose d'extrêmement marquent
l'effondrement
oui alors parce qu'il a
solution mais ça a été décrit juste
avant la solution qu'a choisi le 2 les
autorités chinoises c'est une solution
extrêmement radical dans le court terme
c'est à dire on confine 7,5 millions de
personnes pourrait se faire pour pas que
ce soit une pandémie donc mais forcément
quand vous prenez sa décision qui est
une décision qui potentiellement peut
avoir des effets positifs à moyen terme
parce que vous faites en sorte qu' il
n'y ait pas de pandémie
à court terme c'est assez violent certes
c'est un choc à la fois d'offres c'est à
dire que plus personne peut aller
travailler et puisque c'est bah oui et
l'été il faut il faut avoir ce chiffre
en tête 28% des capacités de production
manufacturière en chine
et puis aujourd'hui quand vous d'eni
dans l'allée les chaînes de production
sont tellement fragmenté que lorsque
vous voulez produire n'importe où dans
un pays vous avez besoin d'une pièce
chinoise quasiment à un moment ça
s'arrête
c'est pas si grave que cela quand c'est
que temporaire on a n'a pas beaucoup de
stock en ce moment mais on peut quand
même joué un peu avec le stock et puis
se dire c'est pas très grave
savard pas un sou début de débat
d'ailleurs sur la mondialisation des
chaînes de production de trouver émerger
oui c'est un point intéressant notamment
les médicaments notamment pour les
médicaments et pour la vie va beaucoup
de médicaments sont produits en chine
sanofi va reproduire des ça serait
prudente ligne de produit actif et pour
la france on a une petite idée parce
qu'évidemment on dépend beaucoup du tout
ici toutes les marques de luxe c'est
aussi plus de 5 via la direction
mais si c'est aussi là encore une fois
on lave ou raisonnée et on raisonne en
termes de poids mais maintenant tu mets
et d'épidémies en chine c'est à dire ni
quoi enfin le poids de la chine sur la
france donc effectivement c'est un choc
d'offre manufacture au niveau
l'industrie donc l'automobile va être
aussi impactés et surtout un énorme choc
de demande via le tourisme et le
tourisme
et c'est plus et c'est quasiment c'est
plus de 4 milliards d'euros uniquement
les chinois qui qui viennent dépenser en
france donc voilà rien que cela
sa c 4 milliards d'euros ça fait 0 2
point de pipe donc on est au delà de ce
que de ce que prévoit le mini sommet
mais oui ça c'est uniquement si ça se
passe en chine mais oui si manier
commencé à avoir des points en italie et
ederson de comptes dans le monde voilà
vous avez le multiplier et se créent
c'est plutôt des dixièmes de point de
croissance que 1 10e jean louis touraine
va y avoir aussi des conséquences on les
voir économique en chine sur l'ensemble
de l'économie mondiale mais guy
également en france vous pourrez nous
dit vous pourriez nous dire ce soir
qu'il y aura forcément à un moment ou un
autre des zones de confinement dans le
pays c'est ce que dit notamment un
membre de l'institut pasteur c'est
vraisemblable parce que donc ça veut
dire des commerces qui vont s'arrêter du
travail qui va s'arrêter sur tous les
écoles les les lieux de rassemblement
les spectacles les et l'activité
économique mais transitoirement le
confinement
expliquez-nous concrètement parce que je
vous avais dit tout à l'heure que ce
serait peut-être uniquement des petites
zones géographiques ses immenses
mégalopole qui les conduit n'est parce
que j'aime bien c'est par exemple ils
ont identifié la maladie à un stade où
malheureusement il y avait déjà eu
beaucoup de cas qui s'était répandue ou
ça vous le savez le médecin qui
d'ailleurs décédées de cette maladie qui
a été le lanceur d' alerte n'a pas été
entendu au début il a il avait signalé
ces cas et les autorités n'ont pas tout
de suite compris la gravité de ce qui se
passait donc au moment où ça a été
identifié il y avait déjà toute l'agglo
partir desquels il y en a quelques cas
probablement et ce pourrait être ainsi
circonscrit et ceolin pendant quelques
semaines seront relativement isolé on
sait que c'est gérable
franchement sûr que c'est gérable bien
sûr on peut comme ça peut-être une
semaine qu'on finit tel ou tel
arrondissement
car disons que c'est dès 14 ans tony ces
mêmes même à l'échelle à 17 d'une grande
île oui parce que la maladie a déboulé
gens sont contaminés
certes parfois ils ne développent pas de
maladies même s'ils ont le virus où ils
peuvent mettre des fois jusqu'à 28 jours
pour que la maladie apparaissent mais en
quinze jours on peut savoir par les
tests biologiques
les tests sanguins s'ils ont ou pas le
virus donc au bout de quinze jours tous
les gens qui ont été autour d'une
personne contaminée on peut dire
on le virus ne l'ont pas donc on peut
circonscrire s'il voulait et
hospitalisés les malades et laisser les
autres ensuite au bout de quinze jours
pour reprendre le cours de leur vie
donc ce ne sont pas des mesures qui sont
d'une durée prolongée sauf que et ce ne
sont pas 15 jours la 15e jour là il faut
pouvoir le gérer parce que on a ça
semble prime quand même fini il vaut
mieux diminuer une activité quelconque
quelle qu'elle soit mais avoir des
morands - marc la garnache
je pense qu'on a nation de l'expérience
italienne puisque le sert de laboratoire
cette fois ci un c'est que du coup ça va
renforcer pour les activités qui leur
permettent le télétravail est
actuellement en italie ils ont décidé de
faire ça c'est à dire de essayer de
renforcer ou de s'adapter soit parce que
des entreprises avaient déjà expérimenté
ça je pense que ce sera véritablement
une des conséquences vous évoquez
différentes conséquences peut-être si on
a cette généralisation de l'épidémie ces
situations confinement on va voir que
beaucoup d'entreprises vont accélérer
les procédures de télétravail là où
c'est possible c'est possible ces
orateurs bien sûr ou même des usines
parce qu'il ya encore des usines et par
conséquent ça ne sera pas
systématiquement mais je pense que ça
aura un effet à long terme de ce point
de vue d'ailleurs penser qu on est
capable à la fois bien sûr pour des
raisons de cette salutaire mais
économiquement de s'arrêter ici ou là
quinze jours on est capable après enfin
voyez on peut avoir moins de croissance
économique le problème c'est que si ça
dure un peu trop longtemps il peut avoir
des faillites d'entreprises s'il ya des
failles d'entreprise
il ya des du chômage et là on passe
aussi une crise sociale et donc l'idée
c'est bien essayé mais on a je pense les
moyens il faut avoir des moyens au
niveau européen pour justement avoir d
une politique qui essayent à la fois de
préparer et quand même le secteur de la
santé fin j'étais rassuré en vous
écoutant mais enfin quand on va aux
urgences
aujourd'hui c'est déjà assez saturé donc
imagine-t-on qui est une épidémie fort
il va falloir s'assurer qu'il y ait des
capacités d'accueil et ça je pense qu'en
termes d'investissements on peut aussi
en faire au niveau européen et donc au
niveau national et ensuite faire des
politiques ciblées sur des secteurs qui
vont être en difficulté on les connaît
ces secteurs en difficulté donc on peut
dire on accorde un peu plus de
de crédits de trésorerie pour les
entreprises pour qu'elles ne fassent pas
faillite etc
enfin tout ça on a des banques centrales
peut nous aider et ensuite on a des
hommes budgétaire aussi ont-ils se passe
c'est leur budgétaire me semble-t-il
alors c'est pas de la demande en termes
très keynésienne mais on peut très bien
cibler des populations pour que
justement une crise sociale qui ai déjà
parlé de mesures fiscales de mesures on
peut on peut les salaires on sait faire
lorsqu'on fait des primes à la casse
quand il ya un secteur qui en difficulté
on le fait bien
soutien très bien faire ce qu'il ya une
chose bon alors là haut voilà c'est pas
exactement d'actualité mais qu'on
découvre aussi à la faveur de cette
épidémie de cette crise c'est que c'est
qu'au fond une petite décroissance petit
on chine permet de réduire
considérablement la pollution
puisqu'on prend plus l'avion non mais
les chiffres sont impressionnants en en
chine notamment
est ce que quelque part ça peut servir
de laboratoire pour voir s'il faut
sacrifier l'homme pour sauver la planète
c'est une bonne solution c'est sûr mais
c'est parce que c'est dit oui mais
regarde les cartes sur sur la chine ne
nuise aux deux acquisitions à vue et est
véritablement impressionnant dans sa
diminution et des conséquences oui
m'enfin là on peut pas arriver ici c'est
les blême la lingerie de la décroissance
est absolument payer les bénéfices
secondaires du ce du coronavirus sont
exorbitants quand même le prix la
décroissance et la fin des frontières
peut-être quelque chose dont on parle
pas assez et qui est un angle mort de
cette histoire c'est que le continent
qui actuellement ont fait le plus de
changes avec la chine et en matériel et
en hommes c'est l'afrique
et on ne parle pas de l'afrique et je
voudrais savoir si vous non je crois
qu'il y en a parce que sans doute il
n'ya pas le justement les mêmes types de
mesures de protection qui sont faites et
même structure peut-être je suis pas du
tout spécialiste de ces questions mais
c'est effectivement la grande en afrique
cette crise sanitaire l'afrique vous
avec avec aussi peu s'attendre aux yeux
oui il n'y a pas de raison connue pour
que penser que nos amis d'afrique
subsaharienne sont reçoit plus
résistants ou et barrier donc il est
vraisemblable que l'épidémie se
propagera également et qu'elle sera plus
difficile à contenir encore dans des
pays d'afrique subsaharienne où les
infrastructures sont pas toujours
existante même déjà pour les dépistages
si vous voulez pour pour faire des tests
on l'a vu ça s'est améliorée à la faveur
de ce drame de du du sida puis de
l'ebola et c'est donc il ya eu des
choses qui ont été mises en place et l'
oms a toujours insisté sur le fait qu'
il faut pas combattre que une épidémie
il faut créer les infrastructures qui
nous permette de pouvoir être plus
efficaces donc c'est vrai que maintenant
il ya beaucoup moins de territoire en
brosse ou ailleurs qui soit complètement
à l'écart de dispensaires et de lieu où
on peut faire des tests et des plus
résistants quand il fait des grandeurs
des températures c'est sympa moins
résistant il ya moins d'eau dans les os
écrit un virus à arn hun donc comme tous
les corps d'un virus qui qui a la
particularité comme les virus de la
grippe a surtout se développer en
période hivernale
donc c'est pas du tout pareil que le
virus de la grippe mais l'un et l'autre
se développe en pire d'hivernal à la
différence d'âge ans comme la dengue qui
par exemple au contraire eux donne
pendant l'été des risques plus
importants transmis par les moustiques
c'est un mode de transmission très
différents la dengue mais voyez il ya
des ya des virus qui résiste à des
conditions alors pour faire
est-ce qu'on va accueillir valérie
brochard pour pour sa chronique qui est
en lien avec avec cette épidémie le
vaccin on peut l'imaginer quand le
vaccin va se développer j'ai confiance
vraiment l'institut pasteur et beaucoup
de chercheurs de la planète
quelques dents dans les prochains mois
vraisemblablement donc si cette épidémie
dur le vaccin pourra être un secours
importants ou si il y à une résurgence
l'intérêt actuel des chercheurs est de
développer des vaccins contre toute une
gamme de coronavirus c'est à dire pas
seulement contre celui-ci covit 19 mai
contre d'autres potentiels qui à la
faveur de mutation ou d'autres
apparitions de virus risquerait de faire
une nouvelle épidémie vaccins et
traitements il faut et je voudrais bien
je sais que parmi les gens qui réclament
instamment le le vaccin il se trouve
qu'il y en a quelques uns qui ont été
interrogés qui omet ne se vaccinent pas
contre la grippe est aussi banal que la
grippe la rougeole et c'est donc il faut
riche crois qu'il faut remplir
il vient encore d des inepties qu'on
trouve sur internet qui empêche les gens
de se vacciner quand ils sont fausses
qui sont fausses vous faites un petit
appel c'est notamment contre la grippe
faut rappeler
jean c'est dangereux c'est vrai que ce
qu'on appelle la came sur le pic de
l'épidémie soit déjà passé au moment où
le vaccin arrivera allez merci messieurs
vous allez écouter à présent valérie
bouchard parce qu'elle a une une journée
à l'assemblée un peu particulière à nous
raconter ce soir où est-elle valérie
voilà j'espère que c'est pas le
coronavirus par précaution je préfère
rejoindre en plateau myriam bonsoir
allegri alors ce soir pour nous parler
du coronavirus à l'assemblée c'est
exactement alors surtout la question
c'est de savoir si c'est la panique ou
pas à l'assemblée myriam et du coup j'ai
rencontré trois députés qui ne cèdent
absolument pas justement à cette panique
écoutez non j'ai pas peur on à vapeur
faut pas s'alarmer outre mesure
alors faut pas faut pas s'alarmer on
nous dit joachim sont forgés il
n'empêche que la dernière déclaration
vous en avez parlé du ministre de la
santé fait froid dans le dos l'épidémie
est à nos portes at il lancé faisant
référence vous l'avais dit aux récents
cas détectés dans le nord de l'italie
je suis donc allé voir marine brenier
députés au les républicains des
alpes-maritimes
hier ont pensé qu'il y avait deux cas
déclarés dans département donc c'est un
véritable sujet qui nous préoccupe
aujourd'hui un certain nombre
d'établissements hospitaliers ont été
mandatés ont la possibilité de faire un
certain nombre de tests mais au vu de la
propagation extrêmement rapide en italie
peut-être que le dispositif qui a été
présenté est insuffisant et on demande
un engagement supplémentaire de la part
de l'état alors c'est le premier
ministre qui lui a répondu directement
dans l'hémicycle cet après midi le
personnel hospitalier et le matériel
nécessaires sont prêts le système est
opérationnel d'après edouard philippe
mais parler des hôpitaux c'est aussi
pour ugo bernalicis occasion de rappeler
leur situation
quand l'hôpital est en souffrance
hôpital public est en souffrance comme
c'est le cas depuis maintenant je sais
plus combien de semaines de grève
mais at elle fait tellement longtemps
qu'on sait même plus les comptabiliser
c'est pas le meilleur contexte c'est pas
le meilleur contexte pour accueillir une
épidémie une pandémie fin vous l'appelez
comme vous voulez bon
donc j'espère qu'en tout cas le maximum
sera fait pour pour une bonne une bonne
prise en charge
je crois qu'en la matière céder à la
panique s'est jamais la bonne chose à
faire alors on ne cède pas à la panique
et évidemment mais avant de vous quitter
j'ai quand même posé une dernière
question aux députés qu'est ce qui se
passe il ya un cadre de coronavirus dans
l'assemblée je mettrai un masque alors
je me tourne vers vous monsieur monsieur
touraine est ce que est ce que me porter
un masque empêche de d'attraper le
coronavirus il ya toute une vérité de
meuf qui va se développer encore des
plus perfectionnés certains peuvent
empêcher totalement d'autres pauvres
réduire considérablement la probabilité
donc vous choisissez le masque au prix
que vous souhaitez et puis il faut
d'abord qu'il soit disponible en 5
millions d'exemplaires
oui merci beaucoup merci messieurs ont
ce temps on se quitte avec le numéro
aller un numéro important qui est déjà
saturé d'ailleurs pour toutes les
questions que vous voulez poser aux
autorités 0 800 1 130 000 plateformes
téléphoniques gratuites n'hésitez pas à
merci messieurs vous restez avec nous
philippe balland va maintenant parler de
la réforme des retraites
et ce fameux 49 3 qui semble acté face à
l'enlisement des débats alors avant
d'accueillir nos invités retour sur ces
49 3 qui ont fait l'histoire de la vème
république
ces cinémas et éphrem envoie 49,88 c'est
le nombre de fois où le 49-3 a été
utilisé 32 par des premiers ministres de
droite 56 par des chefs de gouvernement
de gauche
alors il y a ceux qui l'ont utilisé mais
à faible dose deux fois pour alain juppé
et jean pierre raffarin accepté
l'inaction serait faire preuve de
faiblesse accepté l'immobilisme serait
faire preuve de faiblesse une seule fois
pour edouard balladur il s'en est servi
pour faire passer la loi sur la
privatisation des entreprises publiques
alors qu'il disposait
une large majorité une seule fois
également pour dominique de villepin
pour faire passer le cpie la démocratie
c'est le débat mais la démocratie c'est
aussi l'action et le résultat michel
debré qu'il a utilisé pour la première
fois qui a lui recours quatre fois la
balle et puis on monte d'un cran avec ce
qu'ils ont beaucoup utilisé sur notre
podium dans le top 3 avec 8 utilisation
on retrouve ex-aequo raymond barre
jacques chirac et du cresson en seconde
position georges pompidou et manuel
valls sur la loi travail et sur la loi
macron qui avait du mal à passer au sein
de la major
nous avons le devoir d'aller de l'avant
de déplacer les blocages nos vieux
réflexes pour consolider la reprise de
la croissance et pourra mener notre pays
vers demain c'est cette exigence qui
m'amène en conscience dans l'intérêt
supérieur des français engagé la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement
mais personne n'arrive à la cheville du
recordman en la matière le champion
absolu
michel rocard la parole est un monsieur
le premier ministre
sans majorité absolue il actionne ce
levier 28 fois en seulement trois ans
quant à lionel jospin françois fillon
jean marc ayrault est pour l'instant
edouard philippe
ils font partie des sept premiers
ministres à ne pas l'avoir utilisé
bonsoir jean philippe desrosiers
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
constitutionnaliste et professeur agrégé
de droit public à l'université de lille
l amont d'un gars va nous a rejoint elle
a qui suit pour s&p ce interminable cet
interminable feuilleton des retraites
trois types au fond de 49,3 dans le
sujet combien de voix vous avez très
très courte majorité michel rocard vous
avez des frondeurs dans votre camp
manuel valls et puis celui comme edouard
philippe c'était le cas je crois
d'edouard balladur
c'est l'opposition qui vous bloque qui
vous empêche c'est le plus rares ce cas
de figure là celui qui va nous occuper
certainement cette semaine ou un peu
plus tard avec l'argent compter trois
mois je me rends compte
2 le sens originel et la dénaturation de
l'article 49-3 le sens original et c'est
un très bel article un très beau
mécanisme l'article 49-3 dans son sens
originel c'est créer une majorité quand
elles n'existent pas ou quand elle est
incertaine en disant à la majorité de la
part du premier ministre ce texte cette
loi pour moi elle est vitale
donc soit avons prôné avec soi vous me
tuer sans la dénaturation c'est
effectivement les cas d'après la firme à
la dure 93
raffarin 2003-2004 de villepin 2006 et
j'en passe vous dit ni ni un recours
pour contrer l'obstruction parce que le
49-3 a une conséquence immédiate c'est
que pas débat sur le texte s'arrête
pourquoi puisque précisément le texte
est vital pour le gouvernement et donc
on ne parle plus du texte mais de la vie
ou de la mort du gouvernement
c'est-à-dire de l'engagement de sa
responsable a rappelé on d'une motion ne
s'excluent ont pas l'habitude de ces 49
3 que le gouvernement engage sa
responsabilité et qu'il ya un vote de
confiance derrière qui n'est pas
forcément à kimba dcc ryori mais il
engage sa responsabilité et les
parlementaires et députés ont la
possibilité alors de déposer une motion
de censure
c'est pas systématique c'est une
possibilité dans l'est dans le cadre de
l'article 49 alinéa 2 cette fois ci il
faut donc qu'il soit un dixième 58
et alors si la motion de censure est
déposée c'est elle qui est discutée mise
aux voix et ne sont comptabilisés que
les voix en faveur de la motion de
censure donc contre le gouvernement et
le gouvernement tombe si une majorité
absolue contre lui alors on en n'est
absolument pas là elsa en revanche on
pouvait s'attendre à ce qu'il dégaine
assez vite puisque on avait compris que
le gouvernement y songeait préparer un
peu l'opinion et puis le vent a tourné
manifestement c'est plus pour tout de
suite c'est ça exactement un vendredi
dans les couloirs à l'assemblée
nationale beaucoup pariaient sur un
déclenchement
dès cette semaine aujourd'hui premier
ministre et bien il a décidé de
temporiser il a demandé à ses troupes de
tenir encore un peu pourquoi
et bien parce que les députés discutent
depuis neuf jours de ce texte neuf jours
dans l'opinion et bien c'est pas un
débat qui s'éternise voilà nos jours
c'est plutôt correct c'est trop tôt il
faut montrer à l'opinion que la majorité
elle veut le débat est là pas peur
l'objectif c'est vraiment de renvoyer la
balle dans le
quand des oppositions le message que
veut faire passer l'exécutif et bien
c'est tous les scénarios sont ouverts 1
49 3 oui ou non poursuivre le texte
enjamber les municipales l'histoire
n'est pas écrite men effectivement le 49
3 et bien c'est pas un mot tabou
le premier ministre il a été interpellé
par le président du groupe l'est
républicain lors des questions au
gouvernement
il le dit très clairement écoute edouard
philippe une seule question se pose
aujourd'hui
allez-vous en matière de retraite
utiliser le 49-3 oui ou non
merci pour votre question a le mérite
d'être simple
est clair lorsqu'il faut prendre ses
responsabilités je le fais sans hésiter
et j'utilise tout la constitution rien
que la constitution mais bien toute la
constitution
j'enfile des roses et ça vous surprend
que le gouvernement au fond temporisa
les tâtonne un peu pour trouver la bonne
fenêtre de tir
il faut dire qu'il ya des élections
municipales il n'est pas question a
priori de les enjamber même si le
scénario avait rouvert
il s'agit quoi de gagner la bataille de
l'opinion de rendre ce 49,3 acceptable
c'est ce qu'ils tentent mais mon analyse
consiste à dire que il se trompe en
réaliser sur mais depuis le début bien
avant le 49-3 ils sont acculés ils n'ont
pas d'autre choix soit ils plongent dans
des des jours et des jours et des
semaines et des semaines de débats sans
fin puisque visiblement l'opposition est
mobilisée disponible est là pour faire
de l'obstruction et je ne cautionne
absolument pas l'obstruction puisque à
mon sens c'est tout à fait c'est tout
aussi une dénaturation de la procédure
parlementaire cette fois ci et il faut
la combattre mais le 49-3 n'est pas la
bonne réponse pour la combattre il
aurait fallu le désormais le
gouvernement disposent d'autres moyens
notamment le temps législatif programmé
mais il sait tirer en quelque sorte une
balle dans le pied en voulant absolument
aller vite on essaie de faire adopter ce
texte avant les municipales faisant
qu'il a été inscrit à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée moins de six semaines après
son dépôt empêchant que le temps
législatif programmé puisse être engagée
et ça ça aurait été une bonne réponse à
l'obstruction parce que ont fixé un
temps pour les différents groupes et une
fois qu'ils ont épuisé leur temps ils
continuent de voter mais ils ne peuvent
plus défendre ses possibilités qui n'ont
pas pu mettre en oeuvre parce qu'ils ont
pris trop tard pour des histoires de de
délai philippe val vous souvenez des
manuels macron qui avait subi d'une
certaine façon à 49,3 de manuel valls
sur son propre texte c'était la loi
macron la loi sur le travail le dimanche
notamment comment vous regardez ce jeu
politique là alors d'abord je pense que
vous avez dit une chose très importante
c'est une très belle disposition de 49,3
parce qu'elle permet de définir de
définir une majorité et c'est dans le
jeu démocratique ça n'est pas du tout
une transformation de la de la
constitution contrairement à ce que
l'opposition que ce soit l'opposition de
droite quand c'est la droite opposition
de gauche considèrent qu'elles soient
quelle qu'elle soit dis à chaque fois
lyrique et non pas de 49 points même si
c'était le diable c'est pas le diable le
49-3 c'est une possibilité pour
travailler pour les parlementaires et
surtout évidemment pour le gouvernement
ensuite le plus honteux je trouve là
dedans c'est que le débat réalité il n'a
pas lieu
le l'obstruction ce n'est pas le débat
c'est le contraire du débat quand on
quand on dit ah bah là ils savent quoi
faire donc et met au lit avec l'ennemi
la marque et à puma et puygrenier un
siège mais des chaises bien bas donc
cessons du monde
non mais c'est se du monde ça
devrait pas être possible d une période
où l'a déjà eu des violences dans la
société la société a une espèce de
tendance à se disloquer et avoir recours
à la violence alors que c'est une
démocratie une fois de plus c'est que
normalement le débat doit primer sur sur
la violence physique
si vous voulez ce cette façon de faire
des parlementaires est un encouragement
aux notes encouragement à la perte de
confiance pour les politiques je pense
que c'est irresponsable de la part de
l'opposition d'agir comme ça parce que
le débat n'a pas lieu
et quoi qu'on pense des retraites
secondes
l'opposition est ce qu'elle a
l'impression comme le dit fait les
balles de rajouter à la défiance au
contraire elle joue à fond la carte
exactement et puis les oppositions de
gauche elle refuse la petite musique du
gouvernement qui voudrait insinué que
c'est de leur faute en fait si on arrive
au 49 3 jean luc mélenchon il le dit
effectivement les amendements sont
rédigées de manière peut-être un peu
ironique un peu ridicule mais en fait
les débats de fond les questions sur les
compensations pour les professeurs les
oppositions pose ces questions quand
même dans l'hémicycle pour les
oppositions de gauche en fait celui qui
va perdre ses nerfs c'est celui qui
perdra la bataille et c'est la bataille
avec un grand l es un grand baie
pour la gauche le problème avec
mélenchon c'est que juste je vais dire
une chose c'est que son parti il le dit
pas il ne croit pas au débat il ya toute
une partie de son parti est une autre
sovo parlementaires qui ne croient pas
aux débats parlementaires mais di croît
dans la rue c'est la rue contre le
suffrage universel
et cette bataille là des amendements
c'est la rue contre le suffrage
universel
c'est peut-être leur amour pour
corollaire le recours aux 49 3 risque
d'attiser la rue je pense que
effectivement d'alain c'est un pierre
195 et de dominique de villepin en 2006
qui ont eu recours aux 49 3 pour contrer
l'obstruction au moment où justement la
rue et est entre guillemets déchaînés ça
s'est très mal terminé de faire partir
le le mouvement social merci infiniment
d'être venu sur le plateau des cp merci
philippe balle d'avoir été notre grand
témoin c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivis très belle
soirée sur lcp et à demain
[Musique]